days Richard M karp distinguished
lecturer I'm Sandy Irani I'm the
associate director of the Simons
Institute and for those of you who are
unfamiliar with the Institute we are the
world's leading venue for collaborative
research and theoretical computer
science and related fields we sponsor
programs semester-long programs and have
a strong fellowship program supporting
the next generation of young scientists
so we established the Richard M carp
distinguished lecture series to
celebrate the role of our founding
director dick karp in establishing the
field of theoretical computer science
outlining its Central problems and a
stunning array of results in complexity
Theory and algorithms
um
the this lecture series is features
leaders in the field and it's geared
towards a broad scientific audience
before we get started I want to go over
a little bit of the logistics today we
have folks attending the talk in person
and we have folks attending the knock
over Zoom if you're in the room and want
to ask a question you can just raise
your hand the room mic will pick pick up
your voice if you're attending by Zoom
I'll be monitoring the Q a and I can
um interrupt with questions as they come
up
um so we're grateful to the many
contributors of the Richard M carp fund
who have made today's uh lecture
possible and the series possible and
we're really delighted today to welcome
our speaker Rahul santanam
you all know he's one of the the main
organizers of the program that we have
this spring and so we're grateful to his
work in doing that
um Rahul is a professor of computer
science at Oxford and a tutorial fellow
at Magdalene College received his PhD
from the University of Chicago taught at
University of Edinburgh after stints at
Vancouver and Toronto before moving to
Oxford in 2016. he's worked broadly
across computational complexity
structural complexity circuit complexity
proof complexity foundations of
cryptography and learning theory
and as you might imagine much of his
recent work is focused on the subject of
this program on medical proximity so his
talk today is titled goodle and the
vicious circle on the infeasibility of
lower bounds so thank you Rahul
yeah thanks for that introduction uh
Sandy and thank you to the Science
Institute for this invitation the
opportunity to give this lecture
um so I'm going to be talking about
um the infeasibility of lower bounds
with the in within parenthesis and in
the um abstract for the talk I said I'll
be spending the first part of the talk
on in feasibility and the second part of
feasibility
but that turned out to be quite too
ambitious when I Was preparing the talk
so most of it is going to be on the
infeasibility
um and um there'll be a little bit about
potential approaches to low bonds at the
end
um so I'm aware that this talk is meant
to be for broad scientific audience but
there's also lots of experts here
um so um what I'm going to do is I'm
going to try to phrase things in a way
so that um I'm not going to get into
definitions too deeply I'm going to
phrase things in a way so that if you're
not an expert you can still kind of get
the conceptual point of what I'm saying
and if you are an expert you'll know the
definition already and I don't need to
explain it to you okay so um feel free
to ask questions at any point okay so um
what I'm going to be doing is telling
you a sort of story about complexity
Theory and about low bounce and
complexity
um and uh there's a human protagonist's
story which is Google as you can imagine
um which is sort of
um maybe not the standard choice I mean
we often think of Turing because of this
impact on the definition of Turing
machines and uh on on general
intelligence as well with the Turing
test which is especially impactful right
now but in terms of low bounds and sort
of like issues around proving low bonds
somehow then girdle is a more um sort of
appropriate figure so he's the main
human protagonist and the main
mathematical protagonist is the Vicious
Circle
um I guess so it's more of an antagonist
than a protagonist as we'll see and um
really the stock is going to be about
the sort of like phenomenal The Vicious
Circle in complexity Theory and
improving low balance
and it's going to be sort of like a
speculative story so
um I'm going to be kind of using
evidence from results that have been
proved so far
um but um there will be sort of gaps in
the story which I'll speculate on and it
might turn out be the case that some of
these end up being filled but maybe also
um I'm wrong and um and and it turns out
that things are very different but what
I really want to do is to get you
interested in the story maybe to
question and challenge it not so much to
buy everything I say
okay
um so um let's start off with um this
famous letter of girdle to for Neumann
from 1956
um which was sort of anticipated the P
versus NP problem it's quite an
extraordinary letter many of you might
have seen it already
um but just to um kind of to look at
what it says um he he kind of like poses
the sort of finitary version of the
enchiladon's problem so El Shadow's
problem of Hilbert is a problem of
weather given a mathematical theorem you
can kind of check efficient effectively
whether that's provable or not
um and and what good loss is that sort
of like a finary version of this given a
formula in first sort of predicate logic
and a number n can you sort of tell if
um the machine
um
um Can can check whether there's a proof
of length n for f
um so he kind of defines his number for
n which is somehow the complexity of
deciding um whether VF has a proof of
land then and he looks at the asymptotic
complexity and how it grows and this
anticipates many features of complexity
Theory I mean in terms of like worst
case complexity in terms of measuring
complexity in terms of the input length
um and considering this problem which is
sort of a version of satisfiability
which turns out to be a crucial problem
and the complete problem so um basically
girl was asking for Neumann about
whether P was equal to NP or not long
before the question was actually defined
um so that's one of
um sort of girl's main contributions I
think even though it was only recognized
later and so that's one of the reasons
he's a protagonist is a stock
um and it's it's quite interesting that
he also raises lots of other questions
that have been of central interest and
complexity Theory the question of
whether numbers are prime can you check
that
um efficiently and it turns out that it
can there's a famous algorithm of
agrawal the question of whether you can
avoid exhaustive search when you're
trying to solve combinatorial problems
um can you do better than exponential
and some of the size of the solution
you're looking for and that's of course
a crucial
um uh kind of question complexity Theory
and there's a lot of work on fine grain
complex see which which aims to answer
this question
and go to sort of like says here well um
yeah it's interesting to know whether
um uh fear of n is greater than equal to
K N or not but yeah it's that's the best
low bound we can show as linear but it
could be that there are efficient
algorithms for this and that is
interesting because if you could have
efficient algorithms then you could
automate what mathematicians do and of
course that's something that
mathematicians are very a question
they're very interested in can they be
automated or not it's something that
makes us anxious and so it's something
that's important to understand
um so okay so so basically we'll be
dealing with P versus NP and related
complexity problems right so
um NP is a problem so solutions that are
verifiable in polynomial time so there
are there are efficient Solutions there
are short Solutions and you can check
that a solution is correct in polynomial
time
um and P is the class of problems that
are soluble in polynomial time uh under
way of looking at it is that NP
um is sort of the set of like
mathematical statements with short
proofs and P um and the question whether
MP equals c is where you can find these
proofs efficiently so that's on the way
of raising this question so this is as
you all know a fundamental question
which has implications for learning the
learning algorithm should be doing
pretty well without knowing whether MP
equals P or not
um it's also kind of fundamental in
terms automated theorem proofing proving
theorems efficiently which learning
almost still can't do and to whether
cryptography exists can you sort of
break crypto systems
um which I'm guessing that machine
learning arguments will never be able to
do
um so there are lots of applications and
not just in computer science but
mathematics and outside so this problem
but what I want to highlight here is
that this is just one of a family of low
bound problems problems where we try to
understand
um like whether problems sufficiently so
whether certain different problems are
efficiently solvable or not and there's
many others of this form and they're all
almost indistinguishable to us for us
given a current state of understanding
so the problem of P space equals P can
all problems in polynomial space be
solved in polynomial time the problem of
NP equals score NP or not whether
um all tautologies have short proofs
um approach that all transition
technologies have short proofs the
question of whether NP has polynomial
size circuits these are all examples of
low Bank problems here we believe the
answer is no for all of these but
um our state of knowledge is is very
very limited
um
and then there are these other problems
that are more fine-grained versions of
this problem right you can ask
um is the satisfy problem which is a
canonical anti-complete problem is that
problem solver in time 100 times n or
not
um where you let's say you pick a turing
machine the fixed number of tapes the
fixed tape alphabet and you ask uh are
100 times n steps required to solve that
and of course we believe not um so
essentially girls question is about k
equals hundred um we believe not but
we're still not able to prove it and
then you can ask by finite reversion so
you can just ask let's say you take
inputs of length 100 000
um does satisfiability on on this input
length have circular size two to the
power thousand right and if not then for
all practical purposes the answer to the
NPO speed question is no because
um like if you can't even solve inputs
of this length then um it doesn't matter
whether like our inputs that are far far
higher can do things in polynomial time
it's sort of isn't going to help us very
much in the Practical uh in Practical
settings and and we believe that these
sort of like finatory versions sort of
behave like the answer to MP versus P
but of course we don't we don't know for
sure
um but I just want to point out that
there's a whole class of problems that
we're interested in here
um and um so what I'll be saying is sort
of relevant to
um uh to to many of them
um so of course there's been like many
attempts to attack the MP versus speed
problem using several branches of
mathematics logic comatorics algebra
geometry finite model Theory and so on
but they've not uh really
um given us much information about the
problem we know as little or less than
we knew probably 50 years ago when the
problem was defined
um so the best known separation we have
is that non-transic linear time is not a
good deterministic linear time
um so record the app users be promised
to show that there's a problem and also
for another time there's not in any
polynomial time bound deterministically
and we don't even know of non-toxic time
n square is not equal to determacy time
N squared so um yeah so we have some
some separations but they're very very
weak and in terms of circuit complexity
we don't know of sat or India any
problem with NP requires circuits of
size greater than C six times n so here
I mean I'm assuming you've kind of heard
of circuits before but they're sort of
circuits are just logical networks which
used to solve finite Boolean functions
so basically you take Saturn inputs of
length n and you ask whether there's
these kind of logical networks of size
very small size of linear size solving
sat and um we still don't know the
answer to that
so in practice that turns out to be very
difficult
um but this is additional difficulty
from the nature of the problem itself
right so um like I've put up like three
quotes here
um the first is from Scott Aronson and
he has a survey um on um SP was his NP
formerly independent this was from 20
years ago and he says again and again in
the survey we'll encounter the bizarre
self-professional nature of p in order
to NP the conjecture that all but
asserts are Titanic difficulty of
finding its own proof what does he mean
here well he means that P note NP says
that mathematical proofs can't be found
efficiently in the worst case right and
he's sort of suggesting that maybe this
applies to the proof of this statement
itself but that's just a single
statement Auto NP statement it's a fixed
statement and he wonders whether
um somehow uh the hardness of keynote
entry is related to the to what the
statement is said
um and then there's sort of like a quote
by ketan mulvale who developed this
geometry complexity Theory approach to
complexity to lower bounds based on
representation Theory
um he asked why should the POS and
people not preclude his own proof by
trying the way of any approach and why
should any given approach be feasible
even theoretically so here he's
interested in like barriers to his
approach what he calls a complexity
barrier to his approach and he sort of
understands herself from sociality the
problem is kind of like posing an
obstacle to his approach
and then here's a sort of like half
serious proof I mean it's not quite
meant to be a formal proof but it's kind
of a proof of UV chains that P and all
the NP this has proof by contradiction
assume P equals NP let why we approve
the P equals NP
um well then the proof can be very fine
polynomial Time by confident computer
Cycles because we can verify proof
sufficiently
um however since because MP you can also
find the proof and since this hasn't
been found yet there's a contradiction
so um so so yeah so this is a series of
course and I think you'll be is well
aware of that but it's interesting that
just to see where kind of this kind of
argument breaks down right so
um well first of all we don't know that
of people's MP is a proof of it it could
be that P equals m people there's no
proof of that fact
um so that's that's what that's
perfectly within the realm of
possibility
um and of course how do we generate a
proof If we know it I mean we might know
that people's MP but we might not have
an algorithm that we can use to kind of
like generate a proof
um so yeah so so so of course there are
holes of this but um but but it's kind
of interesting because somehow it
indicates that the longer we go without
showing that um that P equals NP the
less likely it is at P equals NP because
um that we'll probably be able to come
up with the proof sooner or later if the
two classes are equal so that's just a
heuristic sort of um uh kind of ideas
okay so um so much for uh staff of
Charity of people's NP so given these
two things given the difficulty and
practice of the problem and gave the
self-referentiality of the problem
um we could ask well is it independent
of like formal systems like piano
arithmetic which is where we do most of
them for reasoning for arithmetical
statements or even as a male of Frankel
set theory which is of course a much
much richer Theory um where you have um
um yeah like sets in general and very
large sets so this looks way unlikely at
First Sight because the question of
whether a status form of algorithm seems
like a very concrete Earth medical
statement
um and that arises in a natural way so
it seems quite implausible that will be
independent of these large systems
and obviously if you consider some of
the other kind of problems that I stated
in in the the first slides the financial
statements such as whether Saturn inputs
of 900 000 as circuits of size two to a
thousand these are clearly not
independent of piano arithmetic right
because it's just a finite statement you
can just kind of like check out
possibilities and write a finite proof
either way
um but that's not quite fair right but
it's missing the point because if you're
making the problem finite then you
should make proofs sort of like finite
as well you need to restrict the size of
proofs as well
um if we are interested in this problem
because we we think that two to the
Thousand is infeasible then proofs are
size 2 to the Thousand are also
infeasible and we need you need to be
asking whether the processor size 2-100
or less for example so there are
Financial analogs of the problem but
they don't quite um of this Independence
question and they still make sense
um so uh
yes
so that's the question of Independence
and um of course the way to attack it
was using this other contribution of
girdle which is unprovability so girl
showed that in any original formal
system there are unprovable mathematical
statements statements that are true but
untrueable
um and I mean this is of course like an
extraordinary result which had lots of
repercussions and the foundations of
mathematics and philosophy not so much
in mathematics itself but certainly in
the foundations of mathematics and it
did in logic but maybe not so much the
practice of mathematics
um and and of course I mean it's sort of
like fascinating result because you
could sort of compare it with say the
uncomputability of computational
problems like you say look uncomputable
problems exist that follows just by
accounting argument because there are
more conditional problems than there are
algorithms but here the space of proofs
in the space of theorems has the same
cardinality so of course you can't use
accounting augment you need to do
something more clever and girl uses the
sort of like diagnosization argument so
um like I'm just going to be kind of
references first incompleteness theorem
here so you you take any sort of formal
system that's rich rich enough you don't
need very much actually
um to say Rich enough
um and I'm kind of using the semantic
version where you say it's sound it
doesn't prove any false theorems and
it's effectively asymmetized you can
check whether um a certain um statement
is an axiom or not but efficiently or
just recursively
um then there's a universal statement
the girl's sentence such that this can
neither be proved nor disproved in the
theory
and the idea is that you can sort of
encode the question of whether a
statement has a proof
um using an arithmetical statement and
then you use a diagonalization argument
so he defines the statement fee which is
sort of informally asserting the fee
itself is unapproval in a
um and he shows that you can do that
with an arithmetic and then
um if we
um approval you get that feels true and
humanity is unprovable so that can't be
the case so we know that fee is
unapproval and that means fee is true
and so not fee can't be proven because
of the soundness away so so somehow this
sort of like self-referential statement
sort of like asserts its own property
and therefore it is indeed unapprovable
so um that's kind of like the the way
very very intuitively that the argument
goes but I'm not so much interested in
the fact that that you get an approval
statement this way but rather in the
reason why it's on Google or the proof
right so there's sort of like a self
refresholder here this vicious circle
that we can't prove the girdle sentence
in a sense because we know it is true
um so um so that's kind of like there's
this kind of like paradoxical nature of
the sentence
um and so okay that's interesting but it
doesn't seem to say very much for the
practice of mathematics right because
um on the one hand gurus theorem sort of
like really um seems to um deal a hammer
blow to the foundations of mathematics
because there's no way to effectively
asymmetize mathematics so I'll be able
to prove all true tutorials so that's
that's that's that's unfortunate but um
in terms of mathematical practice in
terms of how we actually do mathematics
um it doesn't seem to have much of an
impact uh immediately because girdle
sentences don't really arise in practice
very much
um that's not the kind of mathematics we
tend to do
but then one might think well perhaps
these kinds of sentences are indeed
relevant for problems such as previous
as NP given the self-professional nature
and similar complexity no Bank questions
so that's the question that I'm sort of
going to explore more in this talk like
to what extent does this vicious present
in complexity Theory as an obstacle to
us proving low bonds
um and and just to kind of like so right
now the evidence might be quite sparse
because well girdle sentences are
preferential people's NP has sort of
like a self proportional nature seems to
that's not very that's not very
compelling by itself I think so I'm
going to consider this other analogy um
to this kind of like these results about
Karma growth complexity and I need to
tell you about complexity is
um so uh chronograph complexity is sort
of like a notion of information of a
strain right so you kind of consider
like a fixed machine a universal turing
machine and for any string X
um or some alphabet you consider you
define the commonweal complexity of x to
be the smallest program that produces
this string um so it's somehow the
smallest string from which you can
generate X
um or the extent to which you can
compress x and by generate you mean that
Universal machine generates it
and just a couple of examples if you
take like a string of all zeros that's
going to have control complexity of most
log n plus order one because
um they can describe a string of all
zeros by using log n which to describe n
and just um constant number of ways to
describe a program that outputs this log
n this end with string given n the
string of n0 is given n but even much
more complicated strings like the first
and bits of Pi you can describe by log n
plus order one bits because there's a
program that given n in binary given
that log n those log n Bits of
information is going to produce the
first n Bits Of Pi just by approximating
pi well enough using
um kind of standard algorithms
um so um there are lots of strings the
strings that we tend to use uh
mathematics often have like small
control complexity
um and uh and some have even much
smaller so if you take a string of like
2 to the N 0 so that'll also have the
normal complexity around log n so you
can compress strings quite significantly
um using um kind of rounded information
in them
um and control complexity has some let's
satisfy some very kind of basic
properties so um for every string it has
more complexity at most the length of
the string plus itself because you can
always describe the string by the string
itself and a program that just copies
the string onto its output right so you
give this the string as input and then
it just copies it out to the output so
that's an upper bound the power
complexity of any string and there's a
simple counting argument that sets it
for every integer n the strings of
complexity at least and that's just a
straightforward counting argument
because for any I they're at most two to
the I strings or complexity I because
the atmos two to the I there are two to
the eye programs and each program can
output at most one string and so they're
at most two of the eye strings of
complex ti so you're just coming over
all these such possibilities you have at
most two to the N minus one string as a
common component still less than n and
there has to be a string of chroma
complexity at least then right so um
Commodore complexity satisfies these
properties that every string has
complexity at most the length its length
plus something and strings required from
local complexity at least and in fact a
random string requires control
complexity is n minus one the same
counting augment uh establishes that
okay
um so there's a sort of like um this the
sort of incompetence theorem which to me
feels like much much stronger than girls
theorem and and um sort of more relevant
to mathematical practice and certainly a
complexity Theory do the J10
um and what Chetan showed is that again
you take any effectively accomaterial
soundproof system
um they're only finitely many M numbers
M such as statements will form the
common complexity of this of a strength
is at least M can be proved in a right
so um this is somehow
um like these statements the more
complexity of string is at least um seem
somehow more natural than a girdle
sentences so that's one benefit of this
um of this theorem it seems to tell us
more about where incompleteness is
actually manifested and then there's a
sort of like strong property that for uh
that after a certain end there's not
going to be any low bounds you can prove
at all right so suppose you're a Karma
grow complexity theorist and your job is
to prove and grow complexity low bonds
um you'd basically be better off being a
pretty strong Mystic because you have no
access to um to to whether uh strings of
hyper complexity or not using any kind
of effectively accent price proof system
so
um it's it's just a very very strong
statement about what kinds of load
balancing they're shown
um and and it says quite a bit about
complexity as well I think but let me
just tell you all the proof of this
because it's actually fairly
straightforward so um suppose for the
sake of contradiction that the
infinitely many amp for which some
statement K of X is at least an approval
in this system so
um for some X you're able to prove that
K of X is at least M for infinitely many
M
um well given any such M you can design
a machine and what the machine does
given M so M can be described with log M
bits the machine will just sort of like
run over proofs to find an X such that K
of X beta equal to n has a proof in the
proof system right we know that for
Infinity many end there exists such
proofs so for infinitely many am you're
going to end up finding such an X and
then this machine is going to Output X
just given these login bits of
information
but that implies that the coronal
complexity of X is most log n plus order
one because you've kind of like produced
the string X
um which is sort of contained in in this
I mean the string is sort of represented
in a serum so you've kind of produced
the string
um using just log M plus order one bits
of information
um but then any it's a sound system so
any anything that you've proven it was
true so K of X is also at least jam and
for Lodge enough n this is contradiction
right so it's sort of just from the
definition of commercial complexion the
basic properties of complexity it
follows that um that this can't be the
case right
um so uh so what does it say okay so
this is something called number of
complexity but what does it say about
computational complexity Theory
um I mean I claim that intuitively it's
sort of like bad news for us as
complexity theorists because
lower complexity is really about
compression it's about saying that
strengths can't be compressed and if you
think about circuit complexity that's
about compression too like when we take
a Boolean function take a truth table
and we want to know whether a small
circuits or not that's also about
compression of course it's a much more
efficient phone compression because you
can recover the truth table from the
circuit um in time polynomial the size
of the truth table and the issue here is
that you can't recover
um and then you can recover X from his
description by turing machine but you
don't have any bound the time it takes
so
um it might seem that circuit complexity
is somehow like much simpler form of
compression
um and that's true but what if you
consider probability in in systems that
are weaker not piano arithmetic in
general or any rational Theory but
theories where reasoning is bounded
because those are the kinds of theories
which actually come up in complexity
when we're doing complex theoretic
arguments we're using theories which
have normal time reasoning or proof
systems that are efficient so somehow it
makes sense to compare the power of the
statement or the power of the proof
right so so here I mean this the
statements are saying something quite
powerful the common complexity is large
um but and the proof system is Rich too
so when you kind of like now consider
statements that are about circuit
complexity it makes sense to come down
to the proof systems that are weaker and
maybe some such phenomenon still exist
in that setting right so um so that's a
question is there's a phenomenon of that
sort of that setting I mean the one
thing that's positive about Jaden's
theorem is that it does like tell us
something right we understand
um that it's going to be hard to prove
these lower bounds so that's still
information it could be that that was
inaccessible to us as well that we
couldn't know anything at all but at
least we're able to argue something
about it
um so we're able to prove these
unfruited results which is already
giving us some understanding of the
problem
okay so um so much for Jayden's theorem
and what it said about complexity so
again this is like this Vicious Circle
phenomenon so intuitively we can't prove
that strings of hypoall complexity
because they do right so that's a
vicious circle
and the question the stock is is there
wishes um a circle in complexity Theory
so does the existence of complexity
lower bounds imply that there are no
efficient proofs of low bounds and of
course
um I haven't really told you what
efficient proofs are yet so we need to
to formalize that but at least
intuitively I hope the statement makes
sense we're trying to like take these
statements and see whether they're
resource bounded versions of them and
whether that tells us something about
why low bounds are hard to show okay
um any questions so far
okay so um
so I'm going to start off so so now um
we we're going to get into like um
actual approaches to proving low balance
if there's a circuit complexity approach
which is one of the main approaches in
the 80s and 90s to proving low bounds
for NP to set to to uh attacking
antiviruses fee and the approach was to
kind of like
um consider these combinatorial models
of Boolean circuits right so a Boolean
circuit is just like a logical network
of and or Gates which you use to solve
finite Boolean function so if you have
Boolean function on N input bits it can
be described by a truth table or size 2
to the N so that's
um a very large string and um Boolean
circuit um of polynomial size is a much
smaller object so intuitively
um like you're asking whether these two
to the N lens truth tables can be
compressed um that's what it means to
have a small circuit right
um so it's well known that if a language
is in polynomial time then the finite
sort of like portions of it so if you
take L intersect 0 1 to the N like n bit
strings NL then that has Boolean
circuits of size polynomial n a right so
that's a quite a standard fact from the
70s and therefore to show NP normal to P
it suffices to show that there's some
problem in mp that does not have
polynomial size circuits and this is of
course stronger than npnog the P but it
looks more approachable because we're
now trying to analyze polynomial size
circuits which are more combinatorial
um so maybe we can use kind of
comfortable arguments and um and and try
to um to exploit those uh to get some
information maybe like if the
satisfiability problem is a click
problem they can try to analyze the
structure using controllers
um so well the circuit complexity
approach to previous MP aims to do is to
make progress on this not by directly
attacking this problem but by showing
low bounce and MP4 restricted circuit
classes so you take circuits and you
consider restricted kinds of circuits
maybe circuits with bounded depth you
have a like a fixed number of levels of
the circuit and each level feeds into
the next level or a restricted class of
gates so um circuits that are sort of
weaker than General performance size
circuits let's try to show the low
bounds for those first and then make
progress towards empty versus speed so
this was a program sort of like proposed
well so so Mike sipster had this kind of
like um sort of idea of trying to to use
circuit complexity to Show Low bounds
and then this program sort of develop
naturally and it was very successful at
first in the 1980s there were many many
low bounds that were shown
um for interesting circuit models using
this approach
um so for constant depth circuits which
actually are very interesting from a
logical point of view too because they
correspond to expressibility in first
order logic there were low bounce a
parity function and constant app
circuits for monotone circuits so you
can consider monotone functions where if
you switch an input from a 0 to 1 the
output can't go from one to zero that
that's what it means for Boolean
function of a monotone and you can ask
if monotone functions are computed by
monotone circuits circuits where you
don't allow not caves just monotone
Gates like and Gates or or Gates and um
there were there were strong low bounds
shown by rasbrov on that model
um and then Roswell and smolenski show
low bounce and positive circuits with
Gates that are that check whether the
input has um a number of ones that's a
multiple of a prime or not so those are
more P Gates so there well they seem to
be sort of like and there are many
different techniques involved in these
results so this is a P that is rich in
techniques and seem to be making
progress but um in the 90s progress
ground to a halt and we still have no
idea of NP has polynomial size constant
AB circuits even say with more sex scale
so sex is not a prime so these
techniques don't apply but we have no
idea whether this is or not so you see
if we stock and
um
it was unclear why we were starved so is
there a fundamental reason for this so
does the Vicious Circle phenomenon
somehow play a role here I mean is that
like one of the reasons why they might
be stuck on this problem
um so um there's this kind of really
kind of cool notion of natural proofs of
Ross Brown rubic which says something
about this so
um so what did Ross Brown rudich do so
Ross Brown grudich kind of tried to
think about how low bounds were shown
typically right and the way that low
bounce was shown at that point was to
take like some kind of property of
Boolean functions that implied hardness
right so if you had a circuit class you
want to show that Boolean function is
not in the circuit class you define a
property such that if a Boolean function
has a property then is guaranteed not to
be in C and then you construct some
Boolean function with that property
and it turns out that the properties you
construct often have
um like these features that the property
can be decided in polynomial time so the
property of a Boolean function you
represent Boolean functions by their
truth tables which are long which are of
size capital N
um and and then you ask for the Boolean
function of the property or not that
decision problem is in polynomial time
so that's often the case of the
properties we Define
um this is usefulness okay which is that
if F satisfies a property then F doesn't
have circuits in C and it turns out the
properties we Define are often dense as
well that a noticeable fraction of
Boolean function satisfy them so um it's
a case that Q kind of like uh Satisfied
by by um say one polynomial fraction of
Boolean functions
and just for uh for a picture so let's
say this is a space of Boolean functions
um this would be your your sort of like
um natural property
um um so these would be functions in C
which are just a very small portion of
all Boolean functions because C is to
play some polynomial size bounded class
so there's far fewer functions that have
circuits and C than
um random functions don't have circuits
in C and um the property is sort of a
subset of the heart functions and it's
quite a dense subset of the heart
functions it occupies quite a noticeable
fraction of the space of all functions
right
um and you want this property to be
checkable efficiently so um it's not
obvious at first why this definition is
made but it turns out that the low
bounds that have been shown that thus
far all involve the construction
implicitly of such properties and that's
what made this definition interesting
okay
um so what a restaurant do to show so
they showed first of all that standard
circuit lower bounds so low bound proofs
against restricted circuit classes all
gave you natural proofs against C so
um they could all be um you could all
extract from these low bounds you could
natural proofs which worked against this
class C and then they showed that you
really could hope to use this to get low
bounce against General polynomial size
circuits so under this assumption which
is a standard assumption cryptography
um the assumption that they're hard
one-way functions you can think of it as
maybe saying that factoring is
exponentially hard or the discrete
logarithm problem is exponentially hard
under this assumption which is sort of
like a natural kind of assumption in
cryptography and in complexity there are
no National proofs against polynomial
size right so
um given there's a hardness assumption
which is natural which implies that
there are no natural proofs so um and
and and you'll see later that this also
seems like an example of The Vicious
Circle phenomenon but let me first tell
you how this proof works so just sketch
move to you because it's it's not hard
so given this sort of like result of
gold right Goldwater McAllen
um that um like if you have hard one-way
functions then there's a few random
function family in um polynomial size so
so what does this mean so there's
there's some class of like pseudo random
functions functions that all have small
circuit complexity such as you can't
really distinguish them easily from
random functions so um like if you're
given the truth table of a function you
can't tell whether it's sort of like a
random function or not or one of these
two random functions efficiently so
that's what uh this Lemma guarantees
given the Assumption of hardness of
one-way functions and once you have that
um well it's very easy to see why
natural proofs can't exist because a
natural proof can distinguish random
functions from two random ones all the C
random functions are in this small
portion of the space they all have
polynomial sides while all the functions
that satisfy the natural property
um they are here and there's many of
them so there's a noticeable fraction of
the space so the proper the the
polynomial time function that verifies Q
accepts a noticeable fraction of
functions but not any of these two
random ones so it's really
distinguishings you random from random
so um so and that's in contradiction to
the the Assumption of existence of one
wave functions
so um somehow this kind of like idea of
C Randomness allows us to uh to show
their natural Properties or natural
proofs can't exist
so yeah but let's kind of step back here
I mean it's not that important to follow
the proof but really it's a message
that's more important so somehow there's
sort of like a kind of vicious circle uh
phenomenon going on here too and that we
want to give like the the proofs we have
so far are natural proofs but we can't
give natural proofs of hardness of
Boolean functions against polynomial
size if like certain complexity
assumptions We Believe are true
functions such as factoring are hard so
this is an assumption we believe about
hardness of functions and if this
hardness assumption holds we can't prove
hardness so it's sort of like a similar
kind of like a vicious circle in which
the the truth or the existence of a
hardness assumption implies that you
can't give certain kinds of proofs of
hardness right
um I mean it's not so unlike in like
girls result or Satan's result it's not
clear how some sort of diagnosization
argument is going on here but uh but
it's it's sort of like a clue to
something like a diagnosization argument
under the hood of this result
um that there's a vicious circle
phenomenon
um so yeah so so what I want to say
about this is that basically this
concept of natural proofs is really
elegant I mean it kind of like it sort
of explains in many ways why we're stuck
at the place we we are it provides a
dividing line between circular bounds we
know and once we don't as we'd like to
show
but um for me it's not like really a
fundamental barrier in itself but it's a
clue that there's more fundamental
barriers because
um it's kind of like not talking about a
concept that's naturally defined it's
quite an ad hoc concept right it's a
concept that captures the practice of
complexity Theory but it doesn't feel
really fundamental so natural proofs
aren't really proofs in a mathematical
sense
um the proofs of mathematical sense are
proves to be right you know like a
formal system and kind of like inferring
one line from the other that's not what
natural proofs are like at all
um so they don't really tell us much for
the probability of lower bounds
um it's not clear
um exactly what they tell us in terms of
provenative
what we'd like is something stronger we
like sort of complexity theoretic
evidence that for all Boolean functions
um we can't show efficiently we can't
show with a short proof that f is hard
that F requires large circuits right so
and that's something that natural proofs
isn't able to do for us
the aggressive models
okay so um given the sort of like
um yeah this goal that we have set
ourselves I need to maybe be a bit more
precise about what short proofs and some
reasonable formal system means
um so let's say a little bit about that
what what so um like we were quite hand
wavy about this we said uh we had enrich
in our formal system piano arithmetic
zfc we didn't really say much about that
but we need to say a little bit about
what efficient fuel systems are or or
kind of like resource boundary proof
systems are so one way to formalize that
is using propositional proof complexity
where you study the power of
propositional proof systems to prove
your apologies
um so this is of course something that's
of interest to the SAT reunion program
here as well
um so proof system is defined very
generally in this paper of Steve Cook
who's representative here and Robert
recall and it's just in general a
polynomial uncomputable binary relation
such that there is a why such an art of
fee why holes definitely a fee isn't
taught and why is this a proof system
well if fee is in taught there's a a
proof there's a y which proves it so
that's completeness and if there's a
proof then fee isn't taught so that's
soundness so it's definitely if it's
capturing the soundness and completeness
of a proof system and you want this
proves to be polynomial time verifiable
or in the non-informed case polynomial
size verifiable right so um so this is
kind of like a very abstract notion of a
proof
um and um we are interested in whether
topologies have short proofs or not so
given a topology of size and we're
interested in how large a proof it
requires and given proof system are so
the r proof size or fees the smallest
size of an R proof of fee and we're
interested in sequence of rotologies
we're understanding how the proof size
grows with the size of the of the
formula so how large proofs do we need
for given formulas
and this is very closely related to the
MP versus co-mp question NP is not equal
to NP if and only if for every problem
system there are hard topologies that's
not very hard to see okay so this is
related to the fundamental complex
question of whether NP is equal to NP or
not
um and we're interested in these
processor proof systems and from
mathematical point of view in terms of
what they can show about low bonds
um and we're interested um in particular
in some specific ones these fragile
systems which are very natural proof
systems where the proofs consist of
lines and each line is either an axiom
of the system or is derived from
previous Lines by the application of one
or more rules of deduction so that's a
very natural way to do proofs and the
last line of speed the formula that you
prove
um so that's sort of like uh yeah a
natural kind of like cluster systems one
is interested in and we have to consider
systems where the lines belong to some
circuit class so the more expressive a
line is it seems to the stronger the
proof system is or the greater its power
is and it seems that the more we can do
so fragr stands for proof systems where
the lines are formulas and external
trigger where the lines are circles and
I know I haven't told you much about
what the rules of deduction are it turns
out that these Notions are quite robust
and for many different kinds of rules of
deduction or kind of formalizations of
the these classes fragrance EF are the
same
and a major open problem improved
complexity is to prove lower bounds for
these proof systems like how large
proofs do we need for tautologies and
fragrance EF we don't have any sort of
interesting load balance on these so
that's like a major low Bank problem and
proof complexity
um and um now we can kind of like
formalize what it means for a function
to be hard so given a Boolean function
given by its truth table and a size
bound we can write if the function is
hard we can write a propositional
pathology that says that for all small
circuits C doesn't compute F right so
this is saying for all C of size s c
doesn't compute F and it's easy to write
this as a dnf or size order 2 to the N
times poly of s where
um there's like smaller dnfs Each of
which is saying that um that yeah that c
of X is not equal to um to to f of x and
you're just taking the disjunction of
all of these so if the C doesn't compute
F's there's got to be an X where C of X
is not equal to f of x and this is just
a big or of all of these
um of these conditions and the
propositional variables of the formula
encode the circuit C so that's how we
kind of encode these that that function
is hard and presented to the proof
system so you encode the tautology
um and then you present it to the proof
system
and this is kind of like conjecture
rosproof which says that if there's a
function in polynomial time that's hard
on average for formulas then
um but these kind of like truth table
formulas expressing circuit low Bond
topologies don't have short proofs so
essentially this means that Shredder
can't prove any circuit lobands that are
strong right if this complexity
assumption holds then freger which is a
proof system in which we can formalize
much of the reasoning we do can't prove
any circuit lobands at all for any
Boolean function there and that would be
a very very strong consequence like
morally much stronger than what natural
tools tells us because it says we'll
have to come up with radically new proof
techniques to prove no bounds
um and this conjecture what is saying is
that this is implication from circuit
complexity low bar to proof complexity
low bonds for fragile
um and that's kind of like interesting
in itself this attempt to connect
certain complexity to proof complexity
um so it's sort of like an exciting
conjecture we don't yet have much
progress in it but I like to present it
to you to advertise it because I think
it's um it's something that really does
uh should have more work on it
um I mean it'll tell us a lot about the
hardness or low balance if we can
establish this conjecture
so we don't know really like much
Progressive conjecture but there are
recently some other results which are
unconditional
um which kind of bypass this the sort of
conjecture
um so let me just mention a couple of
those to you so like um there's a result
on um this other conjecture called Roots
conjecture which talks about the
hardness of a specific problem in NP so
rather than talking about whether NPS
and P in size poly or not at all it's
sort of like talking about the hardness
on average of this problem with MP
remember circuit size Bound for core
non-term check circuits so it's asking
about a stronger low bound
um and in a kind of a paper with the on
pick we prove that this is
unconditionally not provable efficiently
by any non uniform propositional proof
system so root is just injector itself
might seem a bit sort of like Arcane too
it's a well-believed conjecture but um
it might be hard to access why it's
interesting but the point is that it's
sort of like a believed conjecture for
which you can unconsciously show that in
some sense it's not provable efficiently
I haven't told you exactly what sense
but yeah but but but there is sort of a
natural way and they should can't be
pulled efficiently and what's
interesting or proof idea is that it's
really like like girls argument or
chaitan's argument it's like saying if
the conjecture is true then it doesn't
have short proofs right so um girls
argument is saying if it's true it's
unprovable and here if it's true it
doesn't have short proofs
um so that's sort of like
and and formal kind of instantiation of
The Vicious Circle phenomenon that this
conjunction doesn't have efficient
problems with proofs if it is true right
this truth precludes that it has
efficient proofs so it's sort of like
evidence I think that this vicious cyber
formula is present in complexity theory
in like a deeper way
um and there's other evidence of that
sort so there's a different way in which
you can formalize proofs using fragments
of piano arithmetic which use polynomial
Prime reasoning
um and their examples like Cook Steve
Cook's Theory PV or sandbas who's here
has kind of like Theory and hierarchy of
theory that's one too and much of
complexity can be formalized within
these theories right so propositional
proof system inside this property that
you have like a sequence of topologies
and you try to prove them like all
independently each one for length n you
prove with a different proof but
boundary arithmetic does things closer
to practice like you have a fixed kind
of formula formula which you're trying
to prove in the system a proof is a
fixed finite object just closer to how
we um do we do it in in real life and so
it's interesting to ask
um when um it's kind of defined um
appropriately I'm not going to say much
what efficiently refined Concepts but
essentially you try to model polynomial
time reasoning within this Theory you're
saying that you're only working with uh
efficient Concepts and natural Concepts
that are too rich or too complex
and there's a couple of results recently
including a very recent one of um uh Lee
and Oliveira which say that certain kind
of results strong low bonds can't be
proved unconditionally in these in these
systems of prolonged reasoning and I
mean the the formalization is important
here too but I'm suppressing it because
I just think the message which is that
you unconditionally can't prove these
results is is very interesting in itself
um so I mean sometimes we wonder well um
with complexity Theory maybe we're just
missing a trick maybe there's some sort
of like simple way to do low bounce we
just haven't found it yet but yeah I
think the fact that we can't prove these
these terms in PV and S12 strongly
suggest that that's not the case it's
not our fault it's the fault of the
systems we use to prove systems will
work in so um that's that's kind of like
the message here and um and these kind
of like results also work through kind
of like diagnosization kind of like
techniques which are also instances of
The Vicious Circle phenomenon that
strong average case low bounds our
approval and Boundary if they are true
so it works so so the main demo in these
results it's saying that if these low
bands hold you can't prove them of
course if the low bonds don't hold you
can't prove them either because of the
soundness of the system so if the low
bounds are false they can't be proved
but the main the main kind of step is
show that the low bonds are true they
can't be improved and that's what gives
us the untrueable unconditionally
so um yeah so so far I mean I've been
like talking about those vicious circles
phenomenon and it's sort of like that is
a real throne complexity area where you
need to kind of um
um kind of yeah uh confront and work
around that strong circular bonds
preclude their own proofs and restricted
proof systems but you could have a more
optimistic interpretation as well which
is that what you're doing when you're
proving these results is like giving new
connections between circuit complexity
and proof complexity and sort of saying
that maybe like um if you make progress
on on circuit complexity you make
progress improve complexity maybe
they're also resulting in the other
direction and if you could show such
strong links I mean maybe there could be
like a Synergy between the two areas and
we'll be able to make progress much more
quickly than just working on these areas
in isolation so that's a more sort of
like optimistic view
um and let me also point out with these
results I mentioned so far are all
unconditional and they're essentially
low bonds right so we're saying circular
bonds are hard but we are shown
unconditionally that some other low
bonds fold so in a sense we are making
rest on low bounds by showing these
results just in a different way than we
hope to do and perhaps this can be sort
of used exploited too um to to make
progress
um on on circuit mobiles
um and let me just like speculate
briefly on how to go beyond these
techniques so the current results on
hardness of low bonds I mean they use
diagnosization ideas they only work for
formal systems as far as comparable to
the low bounds being shown right if
you're doing if you're trying to prove
no bounds in Pokemon size circuits we
look at systems that formulas for normal
time reasoning and we show that they
can't show these lower bounds
um what if you have systems that are
much richer I mean do you have any hope
of showing sort of like hardness for
such systems and um let me just put this
out there for those of you who might be
familiar with the Boral determinacy
theorem which is an example in logic and
kind of like the script or set theory of
a statement that requires proofs that
are much much more complex than the
statement right so
um there's um in fact Friedman showed
that the Border diplomacy theorem
requires like uncountably many
iterations of the passive operation even
though it's really just a statement
about sequences of numbers and sets of
sequences of numbers and later Martin
Short gave a proof of it which is
surprisingly not kind of externally
complicated as an inductive proof uses
transparent induction and establishes it
so um this is a case where you needed
proofs that are very very complex and it
turned out that such Crews then existed
and I don't know the history of it but
maybe Martin's final proof was
influenced by the the bidon prove to
resolve that Friedman sure the
independence resolved that Friedman
showed
um and I should point out that this
whole sort of like area of descriptive
kind of set theory and connections
complexity there have been other ideas
before like Mike sip sir when he was
trying to prove constantive lower bounds
was inspired by an Aziz hierarchy Tim
Garris proposed an approach to P was his
NP based on border determinacy which
turned out not to work I mean Paul
Putlocker example but then this is a
different sort of question it's about
showing Independence and it's about sure
whether you can show stronger kind of
uncruelty results using Financial
versions of this result and this is sort
of like an idea suggested Me by
odishovsky that this might be something
to explode so I'm just putting it out
there in case someone's interested in
um in exploring these directions further
um so yeah almost out of time but let me
just say like a little bit maybe about
um like um how would you actually like
get around so this vicious circle is
sort of like present for these very
strong low bounds
um but but it's always for non-uniform
low bounds and could it be that uniform
low bounds are just much easier I mean
after all the subtle NP versus P we just
need to show uniform load bounds not
non-uniform Bonds so could it be that
they're much easier
um and here's like one way to kind of
approach uniform low bounce and this is
an algorithmic approach
um so um here's like a computational
task that I give you like you're given
as input a circuit on N variables the
circulus of polynomial size it accepts
at least a two-third fraction of its
inputs and your task is just to Output
some satisfying input of C some fixed
inputs a y of C that satisfy C with
probability just slightly over 102 to
the end say n to the power 4 over 2 to
the n and you will love to use like
space say quadratic or some fixed
polynomial space
it's a randomized algorithm right so one
kind of like trivial way of kind of
trying to do this is just open a random
assignment of length n and that outputs
any fixed assignment or the property
only one over two to the N so it's and
we need something better than that but
that does output some fixed satisfying
assignments with high probability as
well
another way you could try to approach it
is using the VC random generators if you
had a two random generator from say
Square 10 bits to n Bits you could
output like a random
um output of that generator and that
would have like success 41 over 2 to the
um square root n and that would be good
enough but we don't know C Ram
generators exist so here you're actually
given the circuit
um you're not given enough space to
actually run the circuit but if you look
at the circuit and you need to Output a
satisfying assignment with probably just
over 102 to the N so this is algorithmic
tasks that are given and the theorem is
that if this task is solvable then
polynomial space is not a good
polynomial time so you get a uniform low
bound but it's not clear how to get a
non-formal bond from this and it's kind
of like interesting because it gives
like an algorithmic formulation the free
space Norm of the P problem the P space
now the P problem is about low bounds so
let's say in the polynomials don't exist
But Here by designing kind of an
algorithm whose existence we actually
believe in because under some conditions
there's actually equivalence between
this Atomic task and pre-space and all
the P
um it maybe gives us a way to approach
it since as humans we seem to be better
at designing algorithms than approving
low balance
um and if you're interested in this I'll
be giving a talk here tomorrow morning
at 10 on that in more detail but I I
just thought I present one potential way
to kind of like maybe get get around
these this kind of like Mission Circle
results so um let me just close with
some kind of like thoughts about what
next I mean so this Vicious Circle
phenomenon probably goes much deeper in
the results discovered so far for
example the the unconscious results we
know are all about much stronger low
balance and MP and other polynomial size
at about NP not and Conor constant size
or about the polynomial hierarchy being
separate and so on so we know little
about this
um so it'd be interesting to see whether
for example you can show that one-way
functions exist in this polynomial time
bounded um uh reasoning systems uh or
some other cryptographic Primitives to
kind of like show other results along
these lines I think it hasn't been
thought about that much I mean there are
these recent results but I feel that it
hasn't really been explored as much as
it should have I mean as complexity it
is I guess there's so much beautiful
complexity that's Elementary and and
where we kind of like prove this elegant
results and connections and we might
hope to settle these kind of like open
problems using that those those ideas
too but that seems quite unlikely and I
think we need to think more about the
meta mathematics of of these results
um the other direction is to find low
bound techniques that can't be
formalized with these important
reasoning right an extended Fragger or
in in Boston Theory S12 because it's
quite possible that we will need this
sort of like more complex proof
theoretically complex low Bond
techniques finally to settle um these
questions so like are there interesting
robot techniques that have the property
um and the other thing that I think
needs more work is this sort of like
understanding this algorithmic method
for proving circuit load balance right
so in the previous slide I gave one kind
of atomic approach to uniform no bounds
there's an older approach of Williams
for Brewing circuit load bonds for super
polynomial time classes which was quite
successful including new low balance it
proved for example that non-term stick
cause a polynomial time doesn't have ACC
zero circuit circuits with not sex scale
so polynomial size circuits about six
Gates
um so which is which is quite a major
step forward
um but it's not really understood what
the proof complexity of the result is
like what systems we formalized in what
players are there showing it I mean I'd
imagine that if there's an algorithmic
formulation or low bound it's much
harder to show Independence results but
it's just not a question that's been
explored enough I think
and finally I think it'll be interesting
to find closer connections between
certain complexity and proof complexity
for strong proof systems because there
are these kind of like two major
Endeavors trying to Circuit complexion
low balance trying to proof function low
bounds
um both seem hard maybe you can kind of
show that they're essentially the same
question I mean Christopher's property
Mutual has this great quote about how in
complexity Theory we can't really
increase the number of answers we can
reduce the number of questions so this
is really about that can we reduce the
number of questions and show that these
two tasks are very closely related
okay
so we know exp stays does not happen so
where does this
is
love yeah so why is that not that we can
easily prove that what is that yeah so
there's a crucial distinction between
compensated low balance where you're
sort of like um where your low bounds
per class that is more powerful than the
low value try to show so exponential
Space versus hormonal size and these
cryptographic load balance where like
you're trying to show like like end
users P for a fixed permanently you're
trying to show another time
and all of these sort of like results
are only relevant to the cryptographic
regime which is also the regime which we
are most interested in I mean of course
from the point of view analyzation and
other kind of applications we're also
interested in these exponential time
results but there as far as I can tell
there are no known like obstacles of
this guy it would be interesting to see
if there are but I can't really think
about how this technique produced in
such a sense
[Music]
yeah
oh oh I said um yeah can we put it in
those kind of situations
yeah so so are you sort of suggesting
like if roswell's conjunction were true
then for any function yeah including
functional next so where is that yeah I
mean
um so yeah I mean so so that's a good
question I mean that's so in a way an
Osmos transaction will be like a little
more damaging in the sense that so far
we have no evidence against the hardness
of proving uh I guess the easiness of
fooling the next person up alongside
circus injection that would sort of like
have notifications for that problem as
well so that might require a bigger step
it's not clear the roswell's concession
holds or not so yeah uh it's not it's
not clear with this dividing line has
there hasn't been that much work on it
it's a great question okay
foreign
[Music]
um
so you need like randomized logo
even better
um
I mean I guess what he's doing is is
something a fixed app and then he's
making
um
like any
yeah so the same um so you hit the max
over so you're taking a fixed formula
and plus our credit card login and then
you're looking at um how the sort of
like the number of steps grows with and
where you're looking for a perfect size
and so so I guess in complexity usually
we give F some input as well but here is
f is fixed
important
[Music]
no such Theory can be simultaneously in
some
exercise
is there some criteria one could assign
to
languages in which
okay so in this case you want to be able
to
situations
um yeah so um and
um
um yeah is very very broad well I guess
like in the complexity setting you have
more restrictions
I mean of course One Direction is to
make those results broader but it's
unclear I mean I I would guess if
they're very very powerful Theory
because